there is new video out of nashville
tennessee showing the moment that that
bomb went off on christmas day
this is police body camera video
released last night the
officer in the video was helping to
clear the streets when an
rv exploded the footage also shows the
chaos that followed
what is now known to be a suicide
bombing
investigators have revealed some of the
suspect's actions
as they continue to search for a motive
this morning mola langhi is in nashville
the fbi is piecing together who the
suspected bomber was before the
explosion
prior to the christmas morning blast
that injured three people anthony warner
deeded his house to someone and gave
someone else his car
telling them he had cancer the fbi is
investigating warner's medical records
to see if that's true
david rausch is director of the
tennessee bureau of investigation
clearly there had to be some
precipitating event
that caused the action newly released
police body cam footage shows the eerie
scene before the bombing as a warning
message plays from the rv
that's so weird that's like something
out of a movie like the purge
moments later the rv explodes
then officers begin guiding bystanders
away from the scene
where's your car okay
authorities are also combing through the
63 year old's credit card records which
appear to show
purchases of security alarms and
chemical precursors
material possibly used to make a
homemade bomb rick lottie says he lived
near warner for nearly a decade
he spoke with the suspect four days
before the bombing
i asked him is santa going to bring you
anything good for christmas
and he smiled and he said oh yeah
i'm going to be famous nashville and the
world
will never forget me
elati the neighbor there says that
warner was a recluse who never seemed to
be close to any of his neighbors
after a tense few days here in nashville
officials have been trying to reassure
the public that the city
is safe that there are no known threats
out there
meanwhile jericho the fbi says warner
acted alone
all right mola thank you